I love the Internet but getting a new
wireless router is my personal
technology hell constant battling with
firewalls IP address numbers I can't
make sense of that's why I haven't
upgraded my wireless router in four
years but that's been a big mistake by
avoiding it I've missed out on much
faster speeds new networking features
and some crazy-looking designs I mean
look at this thing okay no this isn't
really a spaceship but it is d-link
brand new AC 3200 ultra Wi-Fi router and
then check out neck years Batmobile like
Nighthawk x6 but do you really need one
of these fancy $300 routers here's what
you need to know about upgrading your
home network if you remember anything
from this video it should be this get an
802 11 AC router new phones tablets and
laptops have AC radios well you only get
faster speeds when they're connected to
AC networks any AC router will get you
faster speeds at a distance than your
older n or G router but before you buy
one decide on what you need I found that
in a smaller space a cheaper AC 1750 or
AC 1900 was just as good as a more
expensive AC 3200 router but where a c
3200 routers like the d-link spaceship
and the neck your Batmobile did make a
difference was in a big house like this
I got much faster speeds at further
distances for instance here on the
second floor I can actually watch
Netflix without it buffering all the
time but even with all these crazy
antennas the range or the distance of
the signal didn't increase with AC 3200
routers you can think of it this way the
signal highway gets wider not
necessarily longer I still struggle to
get a Wi-Fi signal here in my mom's
office which is about 75 feet away from
the router mom are you excited about the
wireless extender you're gonna get for
Mother's Day but those faster speeds
aren't any good if you can't set the
darn thing
and that's number two get a router
that's easy to set up and manage take
that tp-link it's a great deal but it's
setup tool looks like it was designed in
the early 90s Netgear and Linksys on the
other hand were the easiest to set up
and manage on a Windows PC while Apple
was dead simple on my Mac and iPhone
each lets you easily set up security
parental controls and guest access and
when you're setting up try and find a
good home in your home for your router
not in some basement or storage room
another reason to get a new router is
improved security now most of these
routers have the same sort of protection
but the rest is on you please make sure
you change the default network name and
password and make sure that password is
something strong just as important
upgrade your routers firmware so you
have the latest security updates
ultimately I decided to buy the 180
dollar Netgear Nighthawk AC 1900 doesn't
look like that batmobile one but it's
more than enough for my small apartment
and my wireless needs but if you have a
larger house and don't mind having a
small spaceship inside it then the 310
dollar
d-link spaceship is worth it bottom line
upgrading your router is world's better
than it used to be